Basically,
there are a lot of people who say,
Oh,
we need new inventions,
new breakthrough technologies for plugin
vehicles to be practical.
And our position from the start has been
w they are way better than good enough
to get started right now.
The,
the batteries we have and the motors and
the electronics we have are able to make
great vehicles.
Uh,
as you know,
it'd be great to have better batteries
someday as they come in.
That's icing on the cake right now.
There's a good economics case for a
battery technology.
And then on the other side,
every alternative fuel needs a new
infrastructure or new scientific
breakthroughs except this one.
Uh,
you need new fueling infrastructure for
a alternative fuels,
for biofuels.
You need to create more for natural
guests.
The same thing,
but one of our big,
uh,
one of our big gimmicks we had when we
started Kalkaska as we walked around
with this and we said every alternative
fuel vehicle needs a new in new
infrastructure except this,
the plugin card,
this is connects you to today's
infrastructure.
A one 20 volt plug can power most cars.
And when you get to a truck or a big
vehicle,
you're not,
it's going to take too long on one 20.
So you're going to need the dryer plug
in your garage,
a two 40 and you can do that.
But the point is we have the
infrastructure now,
the fueling infrastructure for cars.
When cal cars was founded and we did our
first conversions,
uh,
we put it all into the public domain and
we enabled individuals to do their own
conversions.
At that point it was a strategic goal to
get enough plugin hybrids around the
country to show what was possible.
Since then,
a small ecosystem of companies has grown
up to do conversions of hybrids of
Prius's and that's a mock at around a
million vehicles perhaps.
So those companies are moving ahead.
Some of them have gotten all the federal
approvals and crash testing and so forth
and they,
uh,
they have a business opportunity.
We think there's a much larger business
opportunity for companies to convert
some of the 250 million vehicles that
are not hybrids,
the big gas guzzlers and some of the
that was in the u s and 900 million in
the world.
And a lot of companies will do that
where the federal government comes in
and where local governments come in is
in helping us get there quicker.
So right now,
for instance,
if you buy a new plug in vehicle in the
next year or two,
you'll get a $7,500 tax credit from the
federal government,
which will help a lot to bring down the
price.
Uh,
there are other places in the world
which have even higher incentives in
that,
and there are places that are using tax
policy and so forth because the reason
why we have that credit is not simply
the practical reason of helping these
companies get started and so forth.
It's because the buyer doesn't get a lot
of the social benefits that are driving
a,
I guess,
zipper or a plugin hybrid brings.
It brings some benefits to the whole
society and reducing energy insecurity
and and emissions and so forth.
So you incentivize the buyer for higher
first costs for those vehicles.
Now,
at this point,
within a few years,
it's very possible that the,
uh,
it'll be cheaper to actually buy a
plugin car than a regular car,
and it'll be a no brainer at that point
when we get to that point,
the incentives will be less necessary.